l'histoire les chaussettes c'est très
marrant
salade de fruits joli joli gelés tu
plaisamment vraiment du plaisir et judas
au gésu ça va ça va ça va ça va je suis
un peu crevé mais sans la wii non
maintenant c'est pas aujourd'hui c'est
papon
pourquoi tu es fatigué au n'ont rien de
spécial en fait j'ai joué au poker avec
les impôts de toute l'année ah cool ça
s'est bien passé ça s'est bien passé
les et crucifié un vrai défi toi quand
même parce que la chance elle tourne
oui enfin ça va qu'est ce qu'on ferait
pas pour trente deniers
je n'ai jamais été en contact avec les
romains c'est un mensonge de quoi tu
parles
je sais pas de quoi toi tu peins pas de
poker j'ai gagné au poker
et puis tu sais ce qu'on dit est heureux
au jeu a les pieds qui saigne un tapin
pas non je parle pour moi encore
d'accord oui d'accord
et toi t'as fait quoi et alors moi j'ai
été acheté des clous des clous ouais
pourquoi faire ainsi je te le dis c'est
pas une surprise ah ouais normal oui
mais il faut garder un peu des trucs
sinon ça va ça va il a fait pas mal aux
mains nous non pour le moment
aaa à aa
[__] aaa mais qu'est ce qu'il a voulu
dire en bonne forme pas c'était
l'histoire de la bible racontée par des
chaussettes
il faudra bien qu'un jour ou l'autre
crucifix